(gentle music)
- My secret is.
- My secret is that.
- Oh my God.
People will tell me
that I always look good
and that I am cute or handsome.
And honestly, I don't believe it
because I have insecurity issues.
(gentle music)
- My secret is that I am 22 years old.
I've never dated anyone, never been loved,
and I've never had my first kiss.
(gentle music)
- My secret is it's been ten years
since I've felt comfortable
coming back to San Diego
since I lost my mother.
(gentle music)
- I am really obsessed
with my figure and my body
and even though I know I
should be really proud about it
and hold it strong and
confident, I tend to not
and I am really hard on myself,
so that is my secret.
(gentle music)
- I think my boyfriend's cheating on me,
but I'm still nice to
him and I don't know why.
(gentle music)
- When I was a kid, my
dad used to beat me.
(gentle music)
- The reason I have so many tattoos is
because it makes me feel closer to my dad.
(gentle music)
- My secret is sometimes
I forget how to breathe.
(gentle music)
- My secret is I'm happy.
I don't know a hundred
percent where I'm going,
but I'm okay.
Yeah.
(gentle music)
- My secret is that I've been in school,
college, for eight years now
and still don't feel like I have any clue
as to what I want to do.
(gentle music)
- I dated a guy for a year
and I was proposed to,
but I've never been in love before.
(gentle music)
- A guy recently slept with me
and then the following day afterwards,
he told me that he wanted
to ask my friend out
instead of be anything with me.
(gentle music)
- I have an irrational fear
of losing the people
closest to me all the time.
(gentle music)
- My secret is that I
don't really trust people
and I have to convince myself
that not everybody is evil.
(gentle music)
- So I went to the ATM to pull out money
and it didn't work and I realized
that there was a process
already with the machine
so 60 bucks came out from the
ATM with nobody around me,
so I had no choice but to take it
and it was during a weekend.
so the bank was closed
so we didn't have any
choice but to keep it.
And yeah, I feel terrible about that.
But yeah, I stole pretty much
60 bucks from someone, sorry.
(gentle music)
- My secret is I once stole a car.
- I love dogs and animals
more than I love people.
Like if I had to choose
between a dog and a human,
the dog would win.
There was a dog.
- My secret is I'm vegan,
but I occasionally eat dairy.
Oops!
(gentle music)
- I don't go to sleep
when I'm supposed to.
(gentle music)
- When I was young, I
used to pick my nose.
(gentle music)
- I have no problem and often times
eat food out of my trash
or if it's been lying around.
(gentle music)
- My secret is that I'm not
wearing a bra right now.
(gentle music)
- My big secret is Dwayne
cannot drive for (bleep).
He cannot drive for (bleep).
You cannot drive for (bleep).
- When I was a young boy,
I used to change the price
tags on toys at KB Toy Store
and go up to the register
and pay less money for the
toy than they were asking.
(gentle music)
- My secret is I
accidentally pissed my pants
at the beginning of a
cross-country road trip
so I had to drive from
North Carolina to California
with piss soaked pants.
(gentle music)
- During my lifetime I've
met many beautiful women,
but I was so fortunate to marry
the most beautiful woman in the world
(gentle music)
- One, two, three.
Only two of us are wearing underwear.
(laughing)
(gentle music)
- As always, thank you guys
for watching another episode.
An announcement I want to make today is
that I just launched my Patreon page.
For those of you who don't
know what Patreon is,
that makes two of us.
I'm just kidding.
Basically, Patreon is a
website where you as a viewer
could go and support
your favorite creators
and whatever projects or
creations they have in the works.
And in return, I give you access to things
that other people don't have access to,
like behind the scenes footage
or like be kind stickers and bracelets
and just other stuff I
haven't thought of yet,
but it should all be pretty cool.
I haven't felt the need to launch Patreon
up until this point
because there was really no need for it
and I didn't want it to feel
like I was just making
money for no reason,
but now I'm at a point where I really want
to make a push with this full time
and didn't just have the
freedom to do this full time
and focus on my content,
would, I, like, I literally,
I can't even imagine
how cool that would be.
Yeah, no, I guess that's basically it.
I'll link it down below.
If you want to support, that'd be great.
But honestly, just having
you guys watch my episodes
is all that I could ask for.
So I want to thank you guys
again and why am I doing this?
I'll see you next week.
(gentle music)